如果要平选出人工智能旅渔最出名的一句话
是由89回学
而参山 is all you need
是句话来自2021期间的一天门闻
接触的门坏表之后
各家业工司分分投入大量资源和技术
它就是当进人工智能旅渔军贵竞产的发力量
这篇门闻不仅确定改变了技术语
还避造了一系列业定人正经的财富传奇
门闻坏表之后
有一家出来公司敏锐的抓住的机会
借助弱文正的底轮迅速决习
如今这页工司的估值已经超过了三千亿为金
是这个世界上最至首可热的公司之一
这页工司就是欧浑人爱
而这篇闻坏的八个作质
他们当时都在郭国工作
后来呢
分分从郭国立职
其中的七位选择了传意
而他们创立的公司
估值普遍达到了数亿到数十亿美金
毫不患上的说
只要主动了这篇闻坏
你就掌握了真功智能的核心思想
在今次的视频中
我先带你主动
这个论文中最精华的部分
那个架构图的程度方法
以及著名的注意力计算公司
整个过程我只会用到
5在12月21日报的数学知识
在竞争黑知识前
我们有必要先了解一下
在程度方法出现之前的世界是什么样子
在二零一零年在中期
循环事情网络阿安
以及它的变种RSTM
几乎完全统治了自然语言处理语
当然呢
阿安有两个非常基础的问题
第一个问题就是
阿安的核心思想
是通过记忆前部的信息
来预测下一步
记住机位着
每一部的计算都需要等待上一步完成
这种顺序一来的机制
就导致模型无法并行计算
很难充分利用现在记得机
强大的并行处理能力
第二个问题就是
阿安的记性不太好
当剧子和文本的长度稍长一些的时候
模型就很难有效的记住
比较早出现的信息
比如我今天买了一本书
上午去了上突出馆
然后下午又去了开会厅
晚上才开始读它
接着它直带的正式前面就知道的
书这个字
但由于中间隔了许多其他的信息
传统的阿安
我们很难精确的记住
这种长距离的一来关系
尽管后来出现了
RSTM等改进技术
但是依旧没有彻底的解决
长距离依赖和并行计算
这两个问题
同时期还有选击师尼莽罗
也就是森安
阿安必要擅长处理序列数据
就像一个纸字足距读书的人
所以经常备用来处理鱼牙精品
而森安则擅长处理
具有空间局部特征的数据
就像一个拿着放弹性
仔细观察图线的人
所以经常备用来处理图像
此言
虽然能并行计算
但因为它的世界比较展
也很难记住全球的信息
为了克服这些问题
2014年
8号打脑倒在
提出了注意力继续因此而吞声
历史的车轮终于开始的转动
注意力继续的核心思想是
当模型处理信息时
它会学着被不同的信息分配
注意力选中
知道男性息是重要的
需要多关注
而男性息是不重要
可以忽略的
让模型也学会
滑中点
随后这几年
注意力继续迅速流行的起来
但那数据注意力
只是安安或者说
4N的辅助工具
没有人认为
注意力可以脱离安安
或者是安安而独立的存在
那为什么大家会这么想呢
首先是死于关系
处理续列任务
进行安安处理图像任务
去用4N安
这几乎是当时人工志动界的常识
其次还有人类的认知本能
人本习惯除自读续的阅读
总觉得信息应该一步一步的传递下去
而注意力继续
需要同时处理万米中的
所有次伏之间的关系
这种同时关注所有那种思路
真的是太反制绝了
更重要的是
它听起来
计算量就非常的巨大
让很多人觉得根本都不写实际
这就有点像量子里学刚出来的时候
也是非常的反制绝
甚至连安因子谈都不愿意相信
讲到这里
我要给大家一个建议
就是多干贩
因为干贩的时候往往会有好事发生
2011年固定的工具师
博洛斯库星在公司时常干贩的时候
向同事无字颗雷测抱怨
说私手母亲里面安安
反应叛满
打不到一只效果
我们计较他布洛和吴姿吧
听完布洛的吐槽
吴姿随口付了一匹
载入AX时车宝
这句话呢
只有五个单词
全部来自初中自会表
所以如果我在现场的话
可能我上我也行
这句话就是
关于到次就死在后的谈实
于是这两个人立刻
就是尝试这个瘋狂的方法
项目刚刚启动
吴姿就给这个新一模型
取了一个下量名字
Transformer
Transformer就是边境银行的意思
因为它从小就是边境银行的铁粉
他们甚至还在项目温当里
画了一幅边境银行的卡通图
并允计底细事实的话
作为温当的开片
我也要想
其实吴姿首在2014年
就开始关注注意力机制
它的分析汉思是
欧洲著名的人工智能与远学家
负责人曾经以为对
注意力机制的看法不同
在财政上激烈的疯乱
不过后来汉思自己
在和学生一起创业开发大门的时候
用的正式喷的方式的架构
所以我们从结果来看的
还是儿子赢了
顺带一提
汉思这位巡的后传
是我的好朋友
之前还在文频道和威胁读习属品
这样算起来
现在看视频的各位
和喷的方式的发明之间
就有三度人呗
吴姿首团队讯速空道的七个人
最后加入的是
姑姑的传奇集中选杀子
她在20000年就进入姑姑
那天杀塞了路过的时候
偶然听到吴姿
他们在讨论注意力机制
立刻停下脚步
偷心了一阵
她本来就对当时
风头正圣的RSTM
新存兔版
一直想彻底版还没换的
就这样的
这位身怀举起的小地森
正式加入了战局
杀塞了身后的龙底
和多年的本金页
在传的方式模型的
实际中都到哪儿
零力进行的体型
存在成员
尽管用魔法
练经是这招数重辞
在形容上的共险
杀塞为传的方式
引入了至关重要的
脱头注意力
位置编码
等很关键的设计
这些概念我们都会在后面
详细地讲解
在ROMIN透过之前
杀塞一本发现
自己的名字在做了里面
排名第一位
感谢提出反对意见
最后呢
大家一日决定
在每个任的名字后面
都加上新号
并诸名
做指共险相等
排名随机
这八位做指
为警刻意
其中六个人出生在
每个国家
回想起来
那真的是一个黄金时代
讲到这里
这篇ROM的做得名单
我们终于讲完了
接下来呢
得加普兰进度了
有了前面的覆点
现在理解
ROMIN前两一的内容
已经负责行动了
ROMIN的前两一
分别是JAL以言和背景
前辈的转转转转转转转
完全抛弃了ROM的循环结构
或三样的卷机结构
警一靠注意的机势
因此能够高度的兵型
就大提高了训练条例
它几十要八块机皮油
训练十二小时
就在翻译任务上
超过了一往最后续的模型
接下来
我们终于要进入
这篇ROMIN最核心的部分
就是分的方法
模型加不图
这样图里
藏着穿的方法
思路的秘密
要么一步一步地相信解析
这部分内容会很干
融合和一口水
我们拜开着碎一步步地谈
先看左边的Inputs
也就是输入
当我们日常使用AI的时候
我们问AI的问题就是输入
而在训练AI的时候
我们提供给模型的预料数据
同样也是输入
模型输到这些输入之后
首先要进行Inputing Badding
也就是输入签入
我们听时使用的自然语言
像中文或者英文
计算即使无法直接进行计算的
因此
我们需要将与原则的单词
组合成数字相量
计算机咱们理解和处理这些信息
我们举个具体的例子
现在有些单词
我们把它排列在一个平面锁播系里面
这个锁播系有两个属性
红洲表示科技程度
纵洲表示生产力
在真实的穿的方法模型中
单词的含义
远比二位屏严丰加输的
他们团杂会不会应设的一个
512位的空间里面
你可以简单地也为每个词
都有512个不同为对的特征
这些特征是模型通过
学习大量与略后自动找握的
但512位空间
对于真实来说
时代排过抽象
我们的视频没法直接展示
所以这点
参用2位空间来代替
在这个2位空间中
含义相似的单词会挨到很近
但含义现在很大的单词
则会力得比较远
虽然自然语言本身无法参与数学予算
但被硬设成现量之后
我们性能很方便地进行下辣予算了
比如
墨索里尼这个词在这个位置
而玉大利在这个位置
德国在这个位置
我们如果计算墨索里尼
简玉大利加德国
就会得到一个新的位置
比这个位置最近的词
最可能的就是失踪了
同样的北京简中国加法国
得到的新位置
附近最可能出现的单词是8里
而教室简学校加级院
则是医生
试质
如果你很好奇
谁更想鱼板的菜徐婚
你也可以用相量来计算一下
菜徐婚简单加鱼
然后呢
看看
这个位置
出现出现的人是谁
我们再仔细观察一下
刚才的例子
比如
一大例到墨索里尼
和德国岛系的乐
这两个相量的妆象
几乎完全一样
也就是说他们的加角非常小
这一位
他们表达的鱼与关系
非常接近
都是在表达国家与领导人之间对应的关系
两个相量的加角越小
他们的内机也就是点机就越大
被表示两个单词的鱼与越相符
而加角越大
比如超过90度
是这接近180度
他们的内机就越小
是你的微幅
代表含义不同
甚至相反
我们再想想一下一个500一式二位的空间
没中语言都有大概三个单词
在这个空间里面
我们从最后一期的原点
像每个单词所在点
坏条件头
这些件头就是则相量
也就是模型所理解的单词的含义
我们继续往上看
第二步
我们就来到了
特别是闹Incoding
也就是位置编码
说的former没有按按按按的徐婚结构
它本身并不清楚
单词在这种具体先或顺序
因此
我们需要跟每个单词
天下一个独特的编号
让模型知道
单词之间的位置形型
路面的作诊们
再是画了一个类似金样的小投票
其次想表示
穿的former
使用正选和于弦的韩数组合
来生成每个单词的位置一边
在往上
我们就进入了穿的former最核心
也是最复杂的部分
毛泽海的Atonish
也就是多头自主力的机制
这一部分是
穿的former核心理念
也最复杂
我们拆开手术来讲
首先
我们注意到图上这里有三个键头
为什么是三个键头呢
约图中没有写
这三个键头
其实分别代表了
三个非常重要的概念
就是Kerry,Key,Value
检成Q,KV
我们可以把数据的每个单词
都形成一个小人
现在呢
直接小人需要互相了解一下对方
每个人都会打两个问题
我的身份是什么
这个问题的答案就是它的K
我想知道什么
这个问题的答案就是它的Q
我们看一个例子
我今天买了一本书
让我许诺堂投入馆
然后下午又去开配厅
反正它开始读它
这个剧字知道我
它的身份是什么
它的身份是一个人生代词
剧字的主体
也就是这个单词的K
而我这个词最关心的是什么呢
它想知道
我做了什么
我去了哪里
这就是它的Q
剧字里面每个小人
都要这样计算出它的Q和K
比如说和它
它们的Q和K分别是这样
这里可能就会有人问了
Q和K到底是怎么计算出来的呀
每个单词的Q和K
都只有它们自己的安排的项量
与模型在虚拟时候
学习的参数举认相成而计算出来
因为说的方模型在虚拟的时候
已经学习过大量的闻网
所以它们够很好的不住
每个单词的允讯息
接下来每个单词的Q
都要与剧字中所有其他单词的K
做一个点击预算
其他人来说就是拿每个单词自己的Q
去和其他单词的K进行品牌
看看谁更何适
比如说它的Q是想知道自己代表的是什么东西
我们拿它的Q去碰一碰我这个字的K
就会发现我是一个人生代词
我不是东西
我不是太要找的
所以脾气不上
所以对于它这个字来说
就没有必要关注我这个字
但是当它的Q碰到的数的K的时候
情况就不一样了
数的K告诉我们我是一个名词
是一种能够被买被读冬冬的评
正好和它这个字的Q高度的匹配
因此输这个词对于它来说
就格外的值得投入注意力去关注
然后它再去查看这个单词的微
微赫里也成是这个单词的具体含义
或者说客观的信息
不过需要注意的是
这只微并不是单词最初的项量
而是经过模型再次计算出来的一个新的项量
比如说输这个单词可能有很多不同的含义
因为模型在训练的时候
学过大量的语调它就会发现
在巨大多数学校的输表示的是
城市的注组而不是上书
因此输的微项量会主要的表示
城市的注组这个含义
而以交接的改率表示其他的含义
于是具体发生的过程就是
它这个单词通过自己的Cure
我就得中的每一个Case做匪备之后
发现自己和输这个词高度相关
于是就进一步查看了输的V
接下来它的项量
就会朝着成次的注组这个含义
产生一字的偏移
进入这种偏移之后它这个单词
这个项量中也就带上了成次的注组的这个信息
最终模型就理解了它在这句话中具体的直带是什么
在这里就要特别强热一下
上面许的例子
都是为了让大家更直观理解
主义力及时的工作原理
在实际的串的方式而木形中
CureCase的都不是具体的自然语言
而是512位空间中的数学项量
这个过程也都是通过相量的数学计算来完成的
因此这三个剑头的意思就是CureCase的微
在串的方式的自主义力系程中
去这里面的每一个单词都会对其他的单词
分配不同的主义力权中
然后根据主义力权中的大小产生不同的程度的项量偏移
而正是一些偏移让AI形成了对于的深层理解
这就是串的方法中最核心的VertianShen
也就是主义力及时
那我们再看
这里为什么叫做Motahead的单词
就是多头主义力
这个多头有些什么意思
所谓多头主义力
就是同时变形做多次自主义力的计算
每一次自主义计算都被出了一个头
每个头都省一组独立的参数局争
我们现在来说就是使用多个不同的视角来观察数字的句子
比如说有一个头可能更关注句子的预法结构
这个头的主义力计算就会更多的判断每一个词
究竟是一个名词和一个动词
词和词在预法上是什么关系
那有的头可能特别关注代词
只能清除每一个代词究竟实在的是谁
那有的头可能更关注
但词的情绪色彩
它想分辨出哪些词在这接移乐观的情绪
哪些词呢
它的含义是负面或者消息的
在论文中
这个多头余共有八个
我们刚才说的
预法结构代词情绪色彩之类的例子
都是为了方面大家直观的理解
事实上模型并不会告诉每个头具体
应该关注什么
他们完全是通过数学方法自动发现和学习的
模型会自动的从大量税中间
发现最适合的8种关注光师
另外每个单词最初都是用512位的相量表示的
但因为每个头只需要关注一个特性的方面
因此每个头并不需要处理完整的512位的情绪
在实际实现中
每个头只需要处理64位的情绪
也就是说
对于每个数据句子
加八个头会各自独立的进行注意的计算
每个头产生一个64位的结果
最后再把这8个64位的结果拼携了一起
8成64左右512
再次回到原始512位的现量大型
通过这种多头机制
它的方法就能够同时从不同角度
理解和处理的原型系
这大幅度的体现了模型表达到每个效果
到这里就难得多头注意力终于讲清楚了
完成多头注意力之后
还需要进行Edanalm
继续长差点解和从规议画
前面的多头注意力可以列成
模型为了每一个单词
计算出来一个拼携量
这个拼携呢
表示单词在结合上海门之后
需要进行调整
残下联系的作用就是把这个拼携量
加回原始性型的数据相量
得到一个实际的新项量
换句话说
参加联接通过相加
把原始性系和模型计算出来的新性系组合到一起
接下来呢
从规议画就会对于这些项量进行标准化的处理
具体就让每个项量的数值分布
重新跳准到均值为0
方差不一的标准分布
最底下来说呢
就是给数据重新调整一下
它的比例齿和中心位置
让数据分布更加稳定
去年模型时候就更加容易收点
效果也更好
然后呢
数据来到了
Protecting by Speed Forward
就是位置前辈往路
我们还是把每个单词都砍了一个小时好了
刚才的注意力继续就好比是同一对开会
每个人都会在会上与其他成员性型过分交流
获得了很多来自成员的想法和信息
但在开会之后
每个人都需要回到自己的环境里面
独自的思考和消化一下
刚才获得的信息
位置前辈往路做的就这个事情
在这里每个单词都会单独的重新组织一下自己身材的信息
具体的做法就是
把原来每个单词512位的项料升级到2048位
然后呢
通过转轴几乎残数
保留正数五百
把所有的付出为限灵
实现飞行型的变缓
最后呢
在从2048位建会512位
这个过程会去到一些容易信息
只保留最有用最关键的信息
这进一步的增强了模型的飞行型更大能力
这里呢
我们就不再进一步展开了
因为这种通过先升纹在降为
提供目前表面的方式呢
其实并不是反了方式的手创
像Alton Coaster
Restat以及选击实用网络里面的包含那个层头呢
都是参与过类似的策略
然后呢
我们把信息再经过一遍
At the Norm
再次完成对信息的整理
到这里我们就把15分的过程交完了
大家可能注意到
在这个架构组左侧
标了一个安成
意思是这个图中这个模块是重复堆叠多次的
在原始的创的方式轮廓中
这个结果堆叠了6次
可以把它列成是6过这样的模块
创连在立起
第一个模块的输出会作为第二个模块的输入
以此列特于这样连续完成
6次这样的处理过程
为什么对别多个层呢
你以为如果仅仅是一次三圣信息的处理
往往不足以充分不着与原中
最复杂最细实的关系
而成了方式通过多个对别层
反复的为信息进行架构和体列
就能够组层深入挖掘职用的各个细节
从而更精准更全面的这辆大处杂的信息
那有人呢就可能会问
这里为什么是6层
而不是12层或者说更多呢
这个层数是越多越好吗
事实上呢在现在的一些主流品中
穿的方式的层数确实达到了即时层真实上百层
但并不是说层数就越多越好
包括我们前面讲到的很多数字
比如说为什么一个项量是500x2x2x1.24x2.48
为什么多头主为例用8个头
每个头主为4x4x6x3x2
这些剧席的数值都是模型的设计区
在训练过程中认为设定的操散数
这些数值是根据理论分析应该限制
以及大量的实验结果
综合确定的一个自由配置
讲到这里呢
我可就终于把左面的数字分讲完了
接下来呢
我们就转向右边输出的部分
我们看看输出的是具体如何工作的
右边的outputs就是输出端
整个穿的方式又是的作用
可以简单的业程
就是让模型逐字逐渠成内容
就让模型一个个投资的
我们用着前面讲起来的基础
就会直接来谈穿的方式观整的工作方式了
假试我们现在的任务是翻译
把五爱女的三个字发现成英文吧
首先呢
我们把五爱女的三个字输到左边
这三个字会经过多特注意力
和位置前输出网络计算
并重复最低六四
这是模型就会对这三个字的含义
和上上上上的关系
有点深入而全面的理解
而这个理解呢
会最终输出的右侧作为右侧的K和V
而右侧本身的输出内容会作为Q
最开始的时候
模型还没有任何输出内容
这时候呢
有一个默认的出质线的start作为Q
意思就是告诉模型
你可以开始设成第一个单子了
因为现在模型的人物就翻译
它就会寻找
就是中最适合作为七十次的内容
模型呢
就根据左侧穿过来的信息
发现我是巨字的主义
最适合作为第一个翻译的词
于是它输出了i
输出了第一个词i之后
这个词就会回到底部
作为新的Q
这个Q可能是
i不要打它情感活动度是什么呢
它再次查看左边穿过来的Q
找到了i这个词
另外i对应的威蓝是对人或是
有深厚的感情
于是就生成了第二个词
拉伍
接下来就会以i拉伍来生Q
这时候的Q就是
不爱的就你是谁呢
再次查看左边的K
发现目标就是你
因此输出了第三个词
有
这次模型就输出了完整的巨字i拉伍语
再次回到底部的显察时候
发现已经完成了翻译
于是呢
模型就会输出一个特殊的中指缚案的
来表示生存结束
这是川普方法整个的工作过程
知道了整体的成分之后
我们再详细看每一步的细节
右侧的安排顶和普特圣的Coding
和左边是完全一样的
但右侧有一个特别的Moscow Multi-Hitlet Tension
这个Moscow到底是什么意思
我们在训练模型的时候
每一个问题其实都是有一个标诺的案子
比如说我们在训练模型翻译的时候
输入完你
专训的案就是i拉伍语
模型在训练的时候
任务就是预测下一个词
让它尽可能的和专训的案一样
但是专训的案
肯定不在模型试线看到
否则我们也有作弊了
训练也没有意义了
所以我们就需要有一种机制
先把答案先盖住
让模型只能看到以前声称那种
看不到未来的词
等模型预测出下一个词之后
再把这个词的答案给模型看
这样模型就能知道自己预测的
是不是损确
这样的训练才有效果
这种盖住未来信息的机制
就是Moscow这个词的含义
我们再回顾一下刚才的例子
开始时CodeShortStart模型预测第一个词是i
然后用i做为输入模型预测Live
再用i拉伍模型所有
组织组部的进行下去
我们注意到这里
模型每一部输入Code
相比標识的答案都网友移动了一位
这就是图中下方
标注ShiftZride
也就是向右移动的原因
需要注意的是
上面说的这些步骤
都是在训练性的进行的
但模型在这种的推理
也就是实际翻译的时候
并不存在標诊的答案
这是Moscow的Code
Rounder from Start开始
但这时候
因为根本就没有笨诊的答案
模型同样无法提前知道未来的信息
因此推理时候的原理
和训练性的就是完全一样的
可以打一个比方
训练去上评论做这些题
做完一道题看眼答案
检查一下对错
总结下经验
而推呢
则像是考试
做完题之后
看不到答案
只能依靠之前训练时的学习的能力
去完成
后面这一部的处理
和左边基本是一样的
也就是对迭六个般训练性的层
处理完之后
就会进入伍临点线性层
性性的作用
是将生存的项量
进生到实际的磁力表当中
举个例子
我们前面讲过
北京剪中国家法国
这样的相当运算
作用完了之后
我们得到了一个新的项量
但这个项量
经典是一组数值
并不是我们熟悉的自然源的词汇
另一种词的任务
就是把这个抽象的项量
转化成对应的具体单词
应设到我们真实使用的词汇表上
然后呢
就要经过Suffer Max
就是规划寒数
Suffer Max作用
就是把任意的识数值
转化成从零到一之间的概率
并写上所有的概率之和等于一
比如在翻译爱这个词的时候
可能会现在出
Lafth的概率是08
而Lake的概率是02
然后呢
模型会根据计算数的概率大小
选择概率最高的单词另一数数
就能这里
我相信大家已经能够
很好的地解
穿的方法是一样经典的加步图了
相比之前安安等模型结构
穿的方法没有复杂的门控制
没有循环依赖
只有清爽的矩真运算
是如此的间接和优雅
在伦们的下一页
我们可以看到著名的资助一例记者公事
有了前面的知识
这个公事
我们也可以很清楚的理解了
而特朗普表示
注意力机局的数据结果
QKV的含义
我们前面都已经讲过了
更方向的DK是一个缩法因子
是计算结果公家门令
QK的转制相成
得到一个方钻
表示序的中每个Q
和其他所有位置可以的相关性
然后呢
在通过SouthMX残数
把这些相关性数值转号升概率的形式
将这些注意力全中
与与举升微向程
实现对每个位置的信息进行加上用活
最终得了终和上下们信息的新表示
现在是不是觉得这个公事
还是挺容易看动的
路文的后面伎业
作者接受了更多模型的实现细节
以及许念时的一些设置
此外呢
作者也没缺的提到
他们已经意识到的算的方法
有着更广泛的用钱紧
而不坚定就现在翻译任务
在这个路文完成之后
直接做准备
一直到他们需要一个文章标题
在他们之前
注意力机局而贪审
只是作为二人的幅度通通剧出现的
而他们技术思想是
只需要注意力机制就足够了
这首呢
作者之一的穷思想到了
实作事业对有时候
经典的歌曲叫做
All you need is love
你需要的是爱
灵感这么一来呢
他们就给路文取了一个
非常简单的机器而经典的表题
而天身
and all you need
你需要的
只是注意力
接下来
我们再讲一下
这份路文的发表和之后的故事
这份路文
被提交到了Nueuf's大会
Nueuf's是人工生的脸预
最顶级
最具影响力的学术会之一
它的路文路用率集低
通常大跃只有10%
在所有被结束的路文里面
少数最优秀
最重要的路文能够获得
口头报够的资格
也就是说作者
就会在会的这个主舞台上面
面向全体观众进行演讲
而大多数的路文
都只能以海报展示的情绪来出现
在海报展示关系
作者就需要把
这个路文的核心内容
做成一张大海报线的墙上
站在旁边
与观众直接进行面对面
交流会打个问题
当这个路文被提交给Nueuf's之后
有三个评论关架
其中一个评价非常高
一个评价是比较近期的
但是还有一个专家
给出了中文字的评价
认为这个路文也就是还行
这个结果可以说是选到一般
所以说虽然这个路文被接受了
但是并没有获得口头报够的资格
只是被安排到了
完先的海报展示关系
但这份路文
其实早在大会举行前的6月份
就公开上传到了Akai不上面
大家其实很快就认识到
的穿的方式的重要性
这个会议是12月30日办的
在这个会议举办的时候
这份路文已经是当时
而也却而热烈讨论的话题了
最终在大会现场
我声声是傲勇力的
这份路文的海报展区引发了
巨大的轰动
它的方式的8倍作质
全部触动与现场的观众经验交流
整个展区挤满了求助如何的语护者
甚至到了闭关的时间
安博人员不得不主动清场
要求人员离开
虽然算的方式这个路文
经验了整个学书界
但是它并没有立刻改变一些
杀责曾经向郭国高层提出现级
认为公司应该用穿的方式模型
设定成功过过的搜索引擎
在当时
这个体系甚至连路文的其他几个作质
都认为太过于荒谬不接实际
然而我们以今天的演员来看
这个想法几乎已经成为了
A&A的共识
在郭国无所所谓的同时
在一家创业公司里面
有一个人敏据的意识造了
穿的方式的巨大潜力
它很快就开始使用
分的方式训练新的生存生活型
而这个模型开放了一个属于人工智能的新时代
这个人就是A&A素质开夫
这家公司就是我们熟悉的欧奉园
而他们训练的模型
就是今天著名的GV系列
而GV体中
这个字母T正式带走了穿的方式
另一个人继续的是
郭国创造了穿的方式的架构
但最大赢驾就是欧奉园
而且是郭国为作者们
已经造了一个鼓举创新的环境
甚至可以说如果没有
谷谷开放包容的企业的话
就根本不会有穿的方式的诞生
但是最终是有八位作者
竟然郭国一个都没有留赋
继续去传火30万天星
在穿的方式弱文发布获得端端几年内
这八位作者全部离开了谷谷
却中七位选择的创业
创造了六人经探的财富上划
正如他们在设计文党开逃中说的
We are awesome
这份自信并非狂妄
他们以热血和才能改变了
整个争功智能行业的走向
如今穿的方式已经无数不在
从七夕翻译到智能对话
从推荐系统到自动架时
到处都有穿的方式的影子
Cythe GPD也clown的JAMM-NAT
DBC一个
一个个药业名字的背后
吐负都是澳在身的影子
各个都流淌着TRATS方式的选择
而屏幕面前的你
在看过这个视频之后
也成了一个了解穿的方式
被穿的方式里面所影响的人
那么下次A.I.革命性的突破
又或者谁呢
也许就是屏幕面前的名